bonjour à tous je suis extrêmement ravi
de de vous annoncer que l'université de
rentrée 2023 du Mouvement Démocrate est
ouverte alors comme comme tout le monde
ici je crois je suis très très heureux
de vous retrouver tous ensemble pour
avoir ce ce weekend de débat et de
convivialité comme on sait si bien le
faire au mouvant démocrate mais il faut
dire que cette édition il y a une une
petite nouveauté et je crois que vous
l'avez vous l'avez remarqué elle est sur
le programme c'est la présence de ces
activités peut-être un peu ét comme le
tir à l'arc avec Marc F ou la partie de
billard avec Patrick minol donc au-delà
du fait que je pense que chaque militant
du Mouvement Démocrate veut savoir
réellement ce que vaut notre ministre de
l'agriculture au tir à l'arc je trouve
que sincèrement ces ateliers ça démontre
ce qu'on fait de mieux au Mouvement
Démocrate la présence et la proximité de
nos cadres qui place les adhérents à
l'écoute je pense quelque chose don on
peut être très très
fierors aussi parler de la météo dans
mon petit Modot d'inttroduction et je
dois dire que j'ai reçu beaucoup
beaucoup de pression pour le pour le
faire mais cette année il va faire beau
tout le weekend à
Guidel alors pour le coup ça c'est pas
une nouveauté mais je pense que c'est
une très bonne nouvelle donc on peut
aussi le saluer je voudrais aussi avoir
un petit mot pour les pour les équipes
du siège qui ont travaillé depuis de
longues semaines pour pour avoir cette
cet
événement et qui va qui va être une
réussite comme comme chaque année donc
voilà je je vais tout de suite passer la
la parole à Dan qui est la qui est un
peu notre local de l'étape chez les
jeunes démocrates puisque tu as grandi
pas loin d'ici et surtout c'est notre
présidente des Jeunes Démocrates de
Bretagne merci beaucoup et ravi de vous
retrouver bonjour à tous ravi de vous
accueillir ici en terrebreton sous le
sous le boton effectivement et j'ai bien
hâte de de faire du tir à l'arc avec
Marc fen je suis pas certaine de gagner
mais plus sérieusement durant le durant
le weekend pour communiquer ou pour
poser des questions lors des plinières
vous avez deux hashtags qui sont à votre
disposition le le hashtag Guidel 2023 et
le hashtag ur
modem merci beaucoup Louise alors si on
est on disait notre plaisir qu'on a de
de se retrouver à Guidel et je pense que
si on est fidèle à Guidel on est aussi
fidèle à son maire qui nous accueille
depuis de très nombreuses années ici et
je voudrais qu'on le remercier vous
donner la parole Monsieur le Maire je
daniel Merci
beaucoup don du mignon
donneel Videl coachtermort et en MVE
armodem ce
que ce que chacun aura compris je
traduis pour les quelquesuns qui ne
sauraient pas parler le Breton
couramment bienvenue à tous et à toutes
chers amis pour ce nouveau congrès du
MoDem où nous sommes heureux de vous
accueillir et où on participera à
certaines de vos activités heureux de
vous voir ici ce soir on sera heureux
d'accueillir madame la secrétaire d'État
demain sur notre réserve naturelle
régionale le grand site du looc
labellisé depuis une vingtaine d'années
espace remarquable de Bretagne et où
avec la Fédération des chasseurs du
morbillan et de nombreux partenaires on
mène de multipes action pour la
préservation de la biodiversité et
heureux aussi de participer avec vous
demain après-midi à une action sur la
plage et je reconnais que si vous avez
été renseigné sur la météo vous vous
avez choisi aussi les bons coefficients
de marée puisque on est à un coefficient
de 112 et les bons horaires la marée
sera montantee la plage sera découverte
et on aura le temps de faire toutes les
actions qu'on veut merci à tout le monde
et bon
congrès on le sait comme tous les ans
vous attendez gu Guidel pour pouvoir
vous baigner dans les eaux à 30°gr de
l'océan Atlantique et en Bretagne l'eau
n'est jamais froide c'est pas un
navigateur qui me dira le contraire je
passe tout de suite la parolele à Jimmy
pin député de la 2e circonscription du
morbien merci Louise euh bah bonsoir à
tous bienvenue en Bretagne merci d'être
aussi nombreux et encore plus encore
plus nombreux demain pour ce weekend qui
nous élève un peu les ça nous fait du
bien merci mode et merci à toutes tes
équipes de faire ça je voulais tout de
suite m'excuser auprès de Sarah demain
pour le ramassage de plage parce qu'à la
même heure Jean-Paul Matth discutera
avec Pierre
larouourou au niveau de
solidarité fiscale et de solidarité
écologique et merci de venir excusez-moi
merci d'en parler tous les trois et je
viendrai vous écouter avec avec grand
bonheur je n'empêcherai pas je sais que
tu parles de tout de suite et je vais
t'écouter aussi tout de suite Sarah sur
la biodiversité parce que j'espère que
dans le mot biodiversité on on a le mot
solidarité mais aussi on a aussi le mot
sobriété vers lequel il va falloir qu'on
qu'on aille et sur lequel on réfléchisse
voilà très heureux encore une fois la
chance qu'on a nous tous les trois tous
les quatre d'être quand même pas très
très loin de Guidel vous remerciz demain
il y aura beaucoup de vagues je crois
sur la plage j'ai vu là tout à l'heure
il y avait des belles vagues coefficient
de Maré de 112 je vous l'AV pas dit mais
c'est quasiment les plus gros
coefficients de l'année donc on va
vraiment avoir un beau spectacle au bord
de l'eau demain voilà merci et puis vive
ce
weekend merci beaucoup Jimmy alors il me
revient de de présenter quelqu'un qu'on
ne présente plus en réalité au Modem et
encore moins en Bretagne Erwan balanan
tu as la parole merci merci à vous tous
très très heureux d'être là j'étais en
train d'essayer de de me remémorer le
nombre de d'universités que que j'avais
fait depuis que j'avais eu cette bonne
idée en 2007 en mai 2007 suite à à
l'appel de François de de de de prendre
cette adhésion au modem je je sans
frimer j'ai un des numéros qui est dans
les premiers numéros de de de cette de
cette aventure formidable c'est une
aventure qui bah qui c'est qui est une
2007 c'est une partie de l'aventure mais
je je tiens à rappeler quand même parce
que je sais que François il est très
sensible on va fêter nos 100 ans notre
mouvement politique va fêter ces 100 ans
et 100 ans c'est pas rien et ça veut
dire beaucoup de ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui de ce que nous avons été et
de ce que nous serons évidemment euh le
le Mouvement démocrate il est né
l'idée de ce centre il est né en
1924 autour d'un certain nombre de
parlementaires qui voulaient être en
rupture avec d'un côté un capitalisme
naissant galopant et puis un communisme
un socialisme on disait socialisme
l'international socialisme à l'époque et
ce que les gens oublient je vais être
très rapide parce que sinon je pourrais
en parler des heures c'est que les gens
oublient c'est que cette ce mouvement
politique c'est le mouvement qui a créé
le mutualisme c'est mouvement qui a créé
la les coopératives et c'est aussi le
mouvement qui n'a jamais lâché la
République et même à ses heures les plus
sombres donc on va fêter nos 100 ans il
faudra qu'on le fête dignement et
j'espère que les les les permanents du
siège et toutes les équipes de jeunes on
fera une très belle fête à ce moment-là
donc voilà après le bulletin météo de de
de le bulletin météo de Jimmy moi je
vais faire le Petit Bulletin sportif
parce que bientôt il y a un match très
important c'est un match qui qui je qui
concarno po euh en football et et c'est
pas c'est pas rien et et donc j'attends
j'espère que François viendra pour ce
match et que on battra dignement
l'équipe de pot voilà bon bonne
université à tout le monde je sais que
j'ai vu le programme c'est un programme
formidable tous les ans le programme
j'ai l'impression que c'est de plus en
plus fort de plus en plus intelligent de
plus en plus constructif vive le modem
et je serai pas là dans 100 ans mais
j'espère qu'il y aura encore du monde à
Guidel dans 100
ans et en Bretagne elle porte haut et
fort et en couleur les valeurs du MoDem
et de l'Union européenne je passe tout
de suite la parole à Marie-Pierre vedren
député européenne merci
beaucoup bonjour à à toutes et à tous
Tout d'abord effectivement bienvenue en
Bretagne bienvenue ici à Guidel et merci
Monsieur le Maire d'être toujours à nos
côtés pour l'ouverture de cette
université autour de François Baayou
autour de nos ministres autour de nos
élus les parlementaires les sénateurs
alors qu'on vient de renouveler
justement le Sénat les députés européens
je vois mes collègues nos élus locaux
nos militants nos amis c'est ça Guidel
c'est les retrouvailles c'est cette joie
de tous se retrouver ici Erwan l'a dit
dans un moment et dans une année
particulière pour notre mouvement
politique mais aussi dans un temps
particulier pour notre pays et pour
l'Europe bien évidemment l'Europe
traverse de profondes bouleversements de
profondes mutations nous avons eu le
retour de la guerre à nos frontières et
puis notre mouvement c'est celui qui a
justement été toujours pro-européen
européen exigeant et qui dresse des
perspectives François a évoqué justement
l'Europe dans une interview ce matin en
disant que sans l'Europe il n'y a pas de
solution et notre nouvelle université le
démontre aussi à travers ce programme
très dense comme la dit Awan un
programme divers qui nous caractérise
nous aussi à la fois la Bretagne et le
Mouvement Démocrate une terre de débat
une terre d'ouverture et si vous êtes là
aussi tous membres amis du Mouvement
Démocrate c'est parce que justement nous
représentant notre mouvement l'ouverture
la volonté d'agir les bâtisseurs de
solutions donc merci à tous ceux qui ont
contribué à l'organisation de ce temps
qui ét attendu je pense à la fois par
mais qui est aussi attendu par
l'extérieur et plein succès à tous nos
travaux et tout de suite on passe la
parole à François Baou président du
Mouvement
Démocrate